so there was a time where we're
exploring as we look at finding the
truth the opposite of truth which was
lies and there was this old norse myth
about how the water knock if it didn't
see truth in you it would drown you and
that was from one story because the
knocks and so many different kinds of
stories but we grabbed on to that and
when we're exploring this idea that
Christophe wasn't happy in arendelle we
said oh my gosh wouldn't be funny if the
knock has to get him to confess put him
on the knock hello
I think he's offering you a ride oh
that's great but ladies first I think he
clearly wants you
yeah thank you mister knock but um I'm
good are you afraid huh no afraid of
what afraid he won't see truth in your
heart and he'll drown you are you what
no of course not
then get on uh-huh okay happy - this'll
be great
Anna what
[Music]
see I know it would be fine okay except
for the part where his heart's full of
lies America
[Music]
are you okay you good I'm good thank you
except you're lying about something no
no there's nothing nothing big anyway
well how about you say it before he
comes back okay uh I don't like so pants
oh that's okay I prefer you in leather
wait that came out wrong anyway so we're
good yeah so that's it that's it
[Music]